y
[Música]
un bus quemado un puente dinamitado y
campos a creados la presión aumenta
sobre la comuna del dogo free en el
centro de malí los atentados suelen ser
atribuidos a los yihadistas de la katiba
de la máquina un grupo vinculado al
qaeda en el magreb islámico' la
intensidad de los ataques ha aumentado
en los últimos meses por lo que los
habitantes exigen que sea garantizada la
seguridad de la comuna según uno de los
habitantes que quiso permanecer en el
anonimato el objetivo de los grupos
armados es aislar esta comunidad hacia
las 6 40 de la mañana un bus de la
empresa de transporte bomba transport
sale todos los días de lo ocurrido para
ir a bamako el bus fue atacado y quemado
completamente por bandidos armados cerca
del puente que había sido dinamitado
hace unos 20 días
[Música]
es la única carretera que sale de togo
free asia obama como pasando por mí o no
seguro hasta llegar a bamako si no hay
más comunicación entre el dogo frío y
bamako ambiente dogo free y seguro no
podemos tener azúcar no podemos tener
aceite los campos también son
regularmente objeto de ataques los
agricultores corren el riesgo de perder
sus cosechas y la comuna de dogo free
podría sufrir una hambruna quemaron el
70 por ciento del agua que cultivamos
más de 30 hectáreas fueron quemadas por
hombres armados ya no podemos llegar a
los campos así que no podemos cultivar
muchas cosas llaman lo poco que podemos
cultivar en nuestra tierra todos los
días hay ataques dogo free va hacia la
hambruna realmente las cosas no van nada
bien nada viendo solicitamos las
autoridades que hagan todo lo posible
para proteger al dogo free los aldeanos
de esta región explicaron que ante la
ausencia del ejército de mali en la zona
fueron los tradicionales cazadores
conocidos como dos quienes decidieron
tomar las armas contra los yihadistas
un pequeño jabalí que corre en el tren
del metro de hong kong busca una salida
y no se deja atrapar
los jabalíes están por todas partes en
hong kong en las calles con sus crías en
los parques e incluso en las fuentes del
centro de la ciudad en hong kong hay
unos 3.000 jabalíes salvajes que viven
principalmente en el campo pero las
edificaciones están ganando terreno y
perturban el entorno natural de estos
animales que ahora están en las ciudades
a muchos residentes y turistas les
parecen adorables ay dios mío me topé
con un jabalí en hong kong
usar un disfraz había un pequeño bebé
detrás de él era tan armonioso sin
embargo la situación dista mucho de ser
tan armoniosa ya que estos animales
pueden contagiar o incluso contraer
enfermedades cuando están en contacto
con los humanos en los últimos diez años
se han producido 47 ataques de jabalíes
hasta noviembre la política oficial
consistía en capturar a los jabalíes
esterilizar a las hembras y liberarlos
en la naturaleza pero una noche de
noviembre un jabalí atacó a un auxiliar
de policía en un estacionamiento
como resultado el policía fue
hospitalizado con una herida de
mordedura en la pierna por su parte el
jabalí escapó por el techo del
estacionamiento y murió al caer algunos
residentes han pedido medidas más
estrictas contra los jabalíes más de 70
mil personas firmaron una petición que
busca una solución no violenta a este
problema pero las autoridades no
escucharon su llamado y dos días después
el 12 de noviembre anunciaron que los
jabalíes serían ahora capturados y
sacrificados con el uso de una inyección
letal
viajeras latinas de como los huevos no
sé escribir ya sabes de crowd acápite
por qué y cómo solucionar este
adolescente colombiano se llama carlos
alberto díaz colmenares tiene 14 años y
publica vídeos donde da consejos sobre
el trabajo en el campo y la protección
del medio ambiente estos son divertidos
y también informativos y también muy
populares en las redes sociales comenzó
a realizarlos con su hermano en mayo del
2020 cuando se instalaron en el campo
con el objetivo principal de promover el
trabajo de los agricultores
a mí me gusta compartir todo el tema la
labor de quehacer campesino en colombia
en todo el mundo porque me di cuenta que
es un trabajo muy duro que entonces es
de las 6 desde las 6 de la mañana hasta
las 6 de la tarde
trabajando con la padre con la pizca y
con los alimentos bajo el sol el
campesino tiene gente lo haga muy
poquito a grandes supermercados oa
grandes empresas que es una gran labor
que empezar a valorarse más
a nosotros nos pasó que teníamos un
cultivo de 1100 plantas de tomates y ya
llevamos tres meses y todavía no
habíamos sacado la cosecha y de la nada
llegó un hongo y nos acabó todos los
tres de meses de trabajo en tres días
entonces también por eso hay
[Música]
y si pedimos un domicilio tú no sabes el
esfuerzo que conlleva a traer esto a la
mesa hay un apoyo que a mí me encanta
compartir mucho es el ir a la plaza
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
del
papa a cuanto estamos poniendo la libra
dos mil pesitos y tres en cinco mil
en la plaza llega el campesino
directamente entonces el campesino no
recurre a un distribuidor para rebajar
los precios a la mitad para poder vender
no todo es después salir adelante
antes de despedirme les recuerdo que
pueden comunicarse con la producción del
programa a través de los contactos que
aparecen en sus pantallas esperamos
conocer todas sus historias fotografías
y también vídeos tal vez usted pueda
convertirse en nuestro próximo
observador hasta pronto